all right hello everybody and welcome to
part three of amnesia the Dark Descent
let's continue through this hole i just
punched with my fist you held to be
Swift
when you activate the first one you hear
that if it stops you'll have to start
over is it all this a bit excessive you
can never be too careful down look Oh
ah seems like there might actually be a
monster somewhere
all right yeah Red Faction
BAM no Russian brennenburg that's what
we are
I think superstition travelers should
adults themselves conversation hearing
30 Years War soldiers bodies Souls
tanked it cited silently shying called
gathers follow steel pray inside damp
burl axe axe blah blah blah Henryk given
noble ten years way down yeah sleepy
hamlet oh my god Black Eagle ok you can
pause the video if you'd like to read
that
alright something about clicking click
click playing clickety-clack
click Moo uh hey aha
must be aah oh oh ooh you look different
yes bingo
ah yeah yeah oh yeah I'm super smart
yeah oh yeah
vamos
yep yep
whoa
oh [ __ ] Oh
Oh light I would have been dumb know
anybody there
hellooo
hellooo
bluh nope
all righty then oh he was kind enough to
open the door for me
I've to thank him later
nope nope nope nope blues [ __ ] [ __ ] aah
no no aah
okay and I wasn't scared laughter yeah
nothing guys
No No yeah
ah the piano I'm not scared of you
mystery piano player ha that's right
that's what I thought
I got what I came for
what the hell did I come I have no idea
did I actually get anything yeah
whatever doesn't matter we're sitting
arachidonic E is not the use but I'm
dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb
oh now I got a goodness oh hey is that
will whoa hey Hou what the [ __ ]
squish roti all right oh hey ah
tinderbox
which I assume is a limited resource Oh
the key that's what I got yeah yeah I
know what I'm doing oh yeah man that is
not a good voice actor all right lay out
your wine barrel mug hammer tool look at
clam person that blood of wine
tell me yeah
we'll finally torch Oh
haha Oh Beryl come on Odie oh I just let
those there's no not cool slice that
fine oh yeah
ooh they're tender Bosley's that makes
up for some of it not all of it still
very upset
ah here's a tool there's a hammer that's
what's good map was talking about all
right that makes up for the toil
oh oh that wasn't anyway I get stuck huh
let me out yeah yeah come on yeah y'all
get
out of there out of here there we go all
right I'm out of here
[ __ ] get on the way all right
that was some whoa whoo be bangin you'll
be bangin nobody be banging what's
happening
Oh feel like my chest is going to bass
oh yeah
okay that makes sense need more oil oh
no I'm out of oil but at least I got my
calamine and my chemistry pop oh I need
to use tinderboxes stop using oil
alright better view him oh this is the
guy from before whoo he died position
100 Oh
that nasty business
Oh aqua regia
aha
flower ah
what's the dealio
no dark steals still people with chains
walking about don't have the guts to
show yourself so brave
lots of barrels off finally
oh that's a lesson oh right yeah
No
hello nope all them guys are cowards did
I need anything else how many
ingredients were there whoa
now once again they're too scared to
come out and face me yeah yeah that's it
okay
Oh aah aah oh [ __ ] what do I do
oh [ __ ] Oh what do we do oh yeah yeah
you better run bear no one messes with
me
all rocks falling
sanity's dangerously low your face is
dangerously low
yep once again tinderbox like great from
the sky mysterious 4th thingy Oh
darkness [ __ ] up
except Daniel is he talking to himself
all right and that's scared come to get
out of here just cuz I'm sprinting for
the exit doesn't mean I'm scared to gosh
oh boy
that whale mating cold alright son right
stop up and stare why can't I just get
out that way I could build a froak I'm
hunting around mysterious chemicals I'm
sure I can find a rope yeah whatever
all right
from down there Oh bliss busking yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah okay all right good
daddy there oh I know
aha I'm not stupid oh but that's gonna
have to wait for another time
am I gonna stop it here but I will
continue playing and I will see you guys
all in part 4 thanks for watching